we started the panel thanking all those
people in Hall H the history of the MCU
the history of our 23 movie infinity
saga which is now complete starts and
ends right there in Hall H from Iron Man
1 all the way to today so it was
important that we unveiled it here
Marvel took over Hall H at the 2019 San
Diego Comic Con this weekend to announce
phase 4 of the MCU and I think it's safe
to say fans were not disappointed with
the exciting announcement of 10 new
films and TV series the audience got a
taste of what's to come from the
superhero franchise over the next two
years and one of the things that is
really getting people excited is
representation Marvel is bringing LGBTQ
2 plus characters to the big screen and
it's about time
although alluded to in thor ragnarok
Tessa Thompson finally confirmed her
character Valkyrie is part of the LGBTQ
2 plus community during the Hall H panel
following the announcement of Thor love
and thunder
[Applause]
I think first of all as king his new
king she needs to find her queen so that
would be an Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige confirmed to io9 that
Valkyrie is on track to find her Queen
telling the outlet how that impacts the
story remains to be seen with that level
of representation you'll see across our
films not just in Thor for now not only
did he share that exciting news but he
also teased that there will be even more
LGBTQ to Plus characters introduced in
the MCU specifically in the new film
eternal starring Angelina Jolie Richard
Madden Salma Hayek and more there is a
rift in the city time is running out
something inhuman approaches we must all
come together and Marvel isn't the only
company ready to put a spotlight in
inclusivity Amazon brought their new
original series carnival Row to
comic-con and star Cara Delevingne
shared that her magical mysterious
character vignette is part of the LGBTQ
2 Plus community in a recent interview
with Variety magazine
the actress got candid about her new
role saying I'm a pansexual fairy all
fairies generally are they don't see
gender it's all about who they are and
their hearts a lot of the things that
weren't written in the script we made
them so obviously I didn't say I want to
be a pansexual fairy but it made sense
that all fairies kind of just love who
they love and during the 2019 comic-con
panel for the highly anticipated series
the actress detailed what fans can
expect from her empowering new character
vineya is I mean she's an amazing
character she it's really yeah been
through a lot she's lost a lot but she
still manages to keep going and getting
back up and continuing to fight for what
she believes in which is love so what do
you think about LGBTQ 2 plus
representation at Comic Con do you think
it's enough are you excited for Valkyrie
do you finally find her Queen
what other films or TV shows would you
like to see more LGBTQ 2 plus
representation let us know in the
comments below
[Music]